I found out via social media that Mike
and Elisa had changed their relationship
status Elisa would post things about
dating other people and I became very
concerned at that point I didn't quite
understand what was going on and we
didn't really talk that much about it to
be honest he just kind of confirmed it
but I don't know why he chooses to live
this way if that's the way she chooses
to live her life I don't understand
I mean to give you a little bit of
context so I was going out line dancing
and our roommate at the time had like
there was this guy that she like really
wanted to talk to and I was like okay
well I'll go talk to the friend and then
you can talk to him and then we'll
slowly like you know so I was gonna like
wing woman for her and so I start
talking to the friend and it's it's just
like this immediate connection and I've
only felt that twice in my life once
with Mike
oh no now I'm getting emotional
um
yeah I've only really felt that twice in
my whole life and the first time was
with Mike but then
my second time was with this guy
and so it was it was this huge struggle
and it was like a month and a half
before I ended up sleeping with this guy
that's not good
Mike was the one who was like oh I think
what you want is to have multiple
relationships
um
I'm sorry I
I think it's Justified cheating
sometimes
how can you justify you're married how
can you go out with another person
as long as it's consensual and all
parties are in agreement and happy
why is that wrong why why do we have to
limit ourselves to the amount of love we
have in our lives you don't have to
limit your love but you can control
yourself and not date other people
she still thinks this is about having
sex but it's not it's about building a
connection and a relationship with
another person
[Music]
I used to think Elisa was the right
person for my son but her having
relationships outside of their marriage
I as a mom
I don't think that's the right thing for
my son
[Music]